meet Monroe Bergdorf a model who has
been controversially appointed the UK
champion at un women a charity that
seeks to improve the lives of women and
girls and promote equality within Civil
Society the corporate sector and
government well it's controversial
because Monroe was to put it in the
modern Parliament a signed male at Birth
or born of bloke as others might put it
17 women's rights groups have signed a
letter to the charity complaining about
a transgender woman representing them on
the committee especially since part of
their written objection is that Monroe
has in the past objected to women making
references to our female bodies although
Monroe did once set up a nightclub
called the Palace so empowering
don't you think it was grouo Marx who
said I don't want to belong to a club
that would have me as a member well I'm
not sure any woman should want to belong
to a group that would have Monroe bured
off as their Champion but there's
another good reason all women should rip
up their membership of this group in my
humble opinion take a look at their
reaction to the revelations of sexual
violence by Hamas in October is there a
reason though Sarah that you can't
specifically call out Hamas un women
always supports impartial independent
investigations into any serious
allegations of gender-based or sexual
violence and within the UN family
these investigations are led by the
office of the High Commissioner of Human
Rights it took the group a full 57 days
after the Hamas attack to make any
official statement and even then that
was to condemn gender-based atrocities
or mass rape as the rest of us call it
seems to me that this group really has a
problem with language and also with
reality so Monroe Bergdorf and the UN
women's group group probably deserve
each other here to debate here in the
studio in London our talk TV
contributors Esther krku and Paula Ron
Adrian thanks so much for being with you
both tonight um what do you make of this
story let's start with you Esther it
just seems amazing to me that of the 33
million or so women in the
UK biological male is is their choice
that's quite an interesting you know I
always think what would happen if we
orded people that are trying to force
their reality onto us because I don't
believe we have an obligation to
validate falsehoods and delusions
certainly the law doesn't public policy
doesn't and I don't think individuals in
a country that lives with as we say we
have free speech I don't think we have
to either um but this Insidious drive
now has infiltrated so many aspects of
society I think on the one hand I
personally cannot be bothered to
constantly be outraged by this because I
know there are some people that will
never have their minds changed which is
fine but on the other hand if we ignore
it what will happen in the future how
will our children be raised how how will
we be able to tackle it if it becomes
like seems like a cancer that will never
go away that's the bigger problem I have
here clearly Monroe buged off you know
this person is very famous in the UK and
this is a trans transwoman that's a
biological man that has believes that
they were born in the wrong body that's
fine but you're insulting women
effectively by saying this is the only
person that can represent women 33 women
33 million women in the UK what do you
think about that because I think they're
not saying that she's the only one but
she's the one they've chosen of the 33
million that that does seem slightly
jarring doesn't it uh no so my position
is of course that the right person is
chosen for the job um and if the right
person is uh Monroe then Monroe is the
right person I I'm not fearful or don't
feel challenged or don't feel that I'm
in competition with Monroe let me just
make it clear I don't know who Monroe um
is personally I've only read about her
um I read the letter that was written to
the um un uh uh women's group UK group
um and what I understood from the letter
the concerns were twofold the first was
that Monroe was not pro women and the
second was that Monroe had written a
number of historical tweets um that were
racist and that were homophobic now for
both of those reasons if they're right
then I would agree because clearly then
Monroe would not
let's just let's just remind ourselves
of exactly what it is cuz if you're
choosing anyone as a diplomat a
representative of an organization I mean
you wouldn't want somebody who for
instance said in called called somebody
on Twitter in 2012 a hairy Baron lesbian
said she wanted a gay Basher TV star and
called the suffragettes white
supremacist I mean it's not it's not the
best Outreach thing is it I mean no but
can I can I just say when we talk about
outrage and when we talk about a cancer
I believe that the outrage and the
cancer is somewhat um somewhat misguided
let me explain to you why I'm intrigued
that we continue to talk about trans
women I'm intg why do you think it is
well I tell you why it is is because
there are certain groups in society that
are happy for what are two marginalized
groups to infight okay and let me
explain to you why because if if this
amount of energy was ex expended on why
it is we still have a gender pay gap of
14.3% if this energy was expended on why
it is that professional sports women are
not being catered For in the same way in
terms of their commercial contracts uh
why it is that they beat up by by less m
is that Serena
and same amount that's a disu AR final
as they were for that's a disingenous
argument then I would kind of understand
these allies who you're pretending
you're pretending not to know why there
is a reason why there's a reason why
we're fixated more on the issues to do
with trans women than trans men because
you don't have sporting organizations
validating transmen in male Sports
because it doesn't exist right there's a
reason why we there's there's all this
sort of controversy around trans women
in female prisons because it doesn't
happen the other way around that is the
reason why and to pretend or to ju
suppose that against other legitimate
issues is completely disingenuous you
know why this person Monroe bergd off
who was born with a penis cannot
represent women in this country because
this person will never understand
understand gender based violence because
this is a biological man they will never
understand how it feels as a woman to
have a biological man in your toilet
because they're a man by the way I agree
I agree with both of you a bit and I
certainly agree with you Paul that and I
would rather never talk about these
issues ever again but unfortunately as
we all know they keep coming forward
because I mean kind of deliberately
provocative things like CH choosing a
biologically born man as a woman's
representative just comes up I'm going
to bring in though we've got coming from
Nashville Tommy Len is from the Tommy
larren is fearless uh uh podcast thank
thanks so much for joining us Tommy what
do you make of all
this well listen I think we need to
start calling this what it is this is an
absolute slap in the face to actual
women and I refuse to use the term
biological women I refuse to refer to
myself as a biological woman I am not a
a woman I'm not cisgender I'm not any of
these other things I am a woman and I
thought that the feminist movement was
cultivated to stand by women real women
and female empowerment and women's
rights and our spaces and our sports but
unfortunately that movement has been
hijacked by what I call the Rainbow
Mafia and now this whole trans movement
has decided that their one goal not
about making equality for Trans people
or awareness for Trans people has been
about overtaking women's Sports women's
spaces women's rights and the fact that
there are now certain activists that
have completely abandoned what should be
the actual feminist movement in favor of
this r rainbow Mafia to me is laughable
and if they're going to call me
transphobic for saying that in the words
of our swimmer Riley gains I would say
well and I guess that makes you a
misogynist we're not using these terms
these labels these definitions anymore
we're going to call things like they are
we're going to speak with science at the
Forefront and we're not going to play
these games anymore at least here in the
United States well whil I've got you
there Tommy in the United States it does
seem the United States is sort of Ground
Zero for a lot of this stuff and I
wanted to take us on to another story
because California I know you're in in
Nashville Tennessee a very sensible
state I'm sure but over in the slightly
crazier State of California uh a new law
has come in I couldn't quite believe
this when I read this a new Law's come
in saying that all large to toy
retailers in California have to have
quote gender neutral toy aisles and
apparently this is because uh uh instead
of having a sort of clear aisle for boys
toys and a clear aisle for girls toys
that's a bit too um it's a bit too uh I
don't know it's a bit too obvious it's a
bit too uh well the 20th century and
every Century before that um and and so
apparently now you know sort of children
and their parents should be able to sort
of skip around the aisles and choose
whatever toy is most suitable for their
gender identity what do you make of this
law and law it
is well I'll tell you I did live in Los
Angeles for three years before I fled to
Nashville Tennessee and I'll tell you
there's a lot of problems in Cali
homelessness taxes regulations illegal
immigration drug use open air drug
markets filth on the streets human feces
on the streets needles on the streets
and I would think that gender neutral
toy aisles would end on the last of list
of priorities for governor Nome and the
rest of the Democrats that control that
state but alas we've discovered that
that is their priority finding retailers
that have already been through enough
with the co lockdowns and shutdowns
finally regaining their ground after
that time also inflicted on them by
Democrat politicians and now they're
going to be fined if they don't have
gender neutral toy sections I'd also
remind people that in California because
they're felon codling laws and policies
you can actually steal $450 more than
these retailers would be finded and that
would be considered a misdemeanor so
let's just put that in perspective you
can shoplift and that's essentially the
same thing as a toy aisle that's not uh
gender neutral that's your priorities
for you I don't know why everybody
hasn't fled that state thank you Tommy
um I I've got to bring that back to the
studio uh Paul Ness I think the idea
here is that we shouldn't impose uh
gender identity performativity I think
is one of the one of the one of the
bizarre terms that it's used uh but
here's something that slightly subverts
that argument um there's a study that
just came out the most popular uh toys
for girls on Amazon jewelry box princess
castle and car Koke microphone and you
don't need to guess which sex these are
the most popular toys for on Amazon
stunt car dboard walkie-talkies and toy
soldier Army swap helmet I think the
point is and it's a shame that they had
to bring in a law uh but I think the
point is is that it's okay if your son
wants a pram and if your son points to a
pram uh on the Shelf buy your son a pram
it's no big deal if being generous if
your son wants to dress up as a um
Disney princess and says I want to dress
up as a Disney princess let your son
dress up as a Disney princess if your
daughter conversely wants to wants to
get a toy soldier Army SWAT helmet
exactly absolutely it's no big deal well
the thing is I think that's a very
generous assessment because these kinds
of people are known for thinking that
everything has somehow been is a result
of social conditioning so I don't think
they're mandating this because they say
it's okay if your son wants to wear a
dress not my house but okay um it's the
point that they they actually think they
actually think it's okay if your son
wears a dress fine but they actually
think young people are socially
conditioned to this even though it goes
against all the scientific data on this
the reality is men like well boys like
things girls like people and that's just
that's just the reality of how we're
genetically predisposed interesting that
you say that that that you think or that
you think that people are suggesting
that they're social conditions in the
same way that you think that somehow
your son will will it's not happening in
my house if he wears a dress it's just
not happening in my house
well that's kind of clear I'd like to
thank both my guests in the studio thank
you Esther and Paul and thanks very much
Tommy for joining us all the way over in
Nashville
Tennessee